Alfre meal has brought out a new
facelift version of the Giulietta it's
closely aligned to the styling of the
flagship Giulia with a more sporty look
especially at the front
oh man Wow Schafer says the car he's
testing is powered by a 1.6 liter turbo
diesel engine with 88 kilowatts or 120
horsepower its combined with the alpha
twin clutch transmission so it's an
automatic but you also have shift
paddles on the steering wheel so if you
want an even sporty ride you can shift
the gears manually we tested the new
engine which is available for the first
time in the Giulietta all in all there
are five gasoline and three diesel
versions these range in power from 77 to
177 kilowatts the darker headlights
surrounds help underline the overall
sporty-er look along with the rear door
handles which are set into the window
frames
the cockpit has an uncluttered and
sporty look air conditioning is included
even in the basic version the newly
upgraded infotainment system is largely
controlled by touchscreen but it does
have a few knobs for key functions too
there are also buttons on the steering
wheel for the onboard entertainment
system and Bluetooth even though the
cabin looks great there are very few
storage options there's a pocket in the
left hand door you could just about get
a very small bottle in there otherwise
only small objects and here you could
get a coffee cup in otherwise everything
down there is taken up with USB and SD
card connections and the drive mode
switch and B space in the back but it's
just covered with plastic what a shame
the Alfa Giulietta diesel can reach 100
kilometers in 10.2 seconds and has a top
speed of 195 km/h Alfa says average fuel
consumption is 3.9 liters per 100
kilometers
the manual says the Giulietta has three
drive modes known as DNA dynamic natural
and all-weather dynamic is the sporty
option of course natural is for
fuel-efficient everyday use and
all-weather is for poor driving
conditions so how does it feel
mono has just selected a dynamic drive
mode and immediately notices the
difference the gas pedal responds a lot
faster the steering is heavier so you
get better feedback from the road and
when you accelerate the gears shift
later joining the braking system also
changes depending on the drive mode and
that's real mode everything is more
sedate the gas is very smooth the gears
change at the earliest possible moment
that makes the Giulietta pretty quiet
especially considering it's a diesel so
its pleasant to drive and the steering
is quite a bit softer thanks to the
electric power steering
amano l can hardly tell the difference
between natural and all-weather mode
that's because the gas response and
steering are identical in both modes the
only difference is the addition of ESC
and ASR stability and traction control
systems which support the driver unload
traction surfaces not that you can drive
off-road of course decimal number in
scale in the phone cut the Giulietta is
certainly not designed for that
it feels most at home on country roads
with plenty of bends all in all mano l
is impressed with the Giulietta the cool
exterior design the smart interior the
engine in combination with the automatic
transmission which works really well
there's just one thing he finds strange
the on-board computer shows the average
fuel consumption and kilometers per
litre does that mean drivers have to
work out for themselves how many litres
induces per 100 kilometers which is
standard on all other European cars
prices for the Giulietta started 21,000
400 euros in Germany